c'est une discipline presque
confidentielle dans le monde du
parapente est certainement la plus
spectaculaire la voltige ils sont une
poignée à la pratiquer à la réunion tous
sont bien sûr des pilotes chevronnés et
certains enseignent même cette
discipline dans leur club sensation
sport les a attrapé au vol rencontre
avec Manu Yan et Alain voltigur que vous
avez peut-être déjà vu évoluer en plein
ciel de Saint-Leu lors des derniers
championnats de France de parapante
notamment dans le parapente il y a
plusieurs disciplines voilà donc il
existe aussi la vol tige qui peut se
dérouler en compétition là on va
chercher plus des sensations
d'adrénaline plus forte on va chercher
sensations de glisse du pilotage un peu
plus pilotage plus extrême et plus fin
suivant les
figures il y a plein de Figur poss
possible et des enchaînements différents
qui sont qui sont possibles avec le
parapante et en fonction du niveau du
pilote il y a une progression un peu
type qui existe on va commencer un peu
plus par des des wing over donc des
balanciers droite gauche on a reste à
petit à monter carrément au-dessus de la
voile
c'estaller chercher un pilotage actif de
jouer avec le vent c'est vraiment on va
chercher vraiment la glisse au maximum
et pour pas mal de figures on va
chercher à faire des grosse prise de
vitesse pour avoir beaucoup
d'énergie le phapente à la base ça fait
partie un peu des sport à risque ou en
fonction de son niveau des conditions
dans lesquelles on se met on arrive à
limiter vraiment le risque au maximum
quand on commence à faire de la
Volti automatiquement on va augmenter un
petit peu les risques donc c'est pour ça
qu'avec le club on
va organiser des entraînements voltig
dans un cadre sécurisé donc on va mettre
un bateau sur l'eau on a des gilets de
sauvetage avec nous pour les essayer les
des figures qu'on a pas encore trop
l'habitude de faire voilà que ce soit
dans un cadre sécurisé que si jamais ça
se passe pas comme on veut qu'on ait le
temps de tirer le parachute de secours
et de tomber dans l'eau
sur la voltge on va chercher vraiment le
pilotage actif en l'air la masse d'air
nous elle nous monte elle nous descend
et puis suivant l'intensité de la masse
d'air on peut être ne serait-ce que
passif parce que on se fait un peu
trballer à droite à gauche comme dans
une rivière ben nous on va chercher un
petit peu ce pilotage actif on va
essayer de c'est c'est nous les maîtres
de du
parap